I have an entire operation around
shopping I take it very very seriously
[Music]
story of stuff begins in our imagination
and in our fantasies that's the space
where we dream about all the things that
we would really really love to have and
what a wonderful life we would have if
only we could have this stuff we have an
actual self who we actually are most of
the time but then we also have a social
self we buy products clothes that
Express who we want to be at any point
in time I have two moods so
I have this mood
and I also
have this mood
Recent research has shown that when we
have too many things we are constantly
dissatisfied I would say yes I do have a
mild problem when it comes to shopping
but I like to think that I could stop if
I wanted to oh my God that's exactly
what an addict says